In this segment, we'll be
talking about how to obtain a
developer key to make YouTube
API calls and
run the sample code.
To do this, we'll need a
registered Google account.
The first thing we want
to do is browse at
a Google API console.
We can find this at
code.google.com/apis/console.
Or we can just search for
"Google API console" in our
favorite search engine.
We'll need to create a project
the first time we open a site.
Projects [? are ?] grouping at
the APIs, and it may make
sense for us to create different
projects for every
new application that we write.
For running the sample code, we
only need one project and
one set of API keys.
After we enable our project,
we'll need
to enable some services.
Let's click through to the
Services menu, if we're not
already on this page,
and scroll down.
We'll want to enable the YouTube
Data API and YouTube
Analytics API first.
Let's toggle the YouTube Data
API from Off to On.
The very first time we do this,
we'll be presented with
the terms of service.
We'll want to read the terms
of service and accept if we
want to be able to
use the API.
Now when we scroll down, we'll
see that the YouTube Data API
has been accepted and enabled.
We'll click On to also enable
the YouTube Analytics API.
The search by topic code
sample requires use of
Freebase API, so we'll need
to enable that as well.
There's a separate terms of
service that we'll need to
read and accept.
Once this is done, we'll need
to access our API keys.
We can do this by clicking API
Access in a navigation menu.
There are two types of API
access, simple and authorized.
If all we want to do is search
for videos, channels, and
playlists, all we need
is simple API access.
The key is already provided
to us in our project.